[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros en esta oportunidad
reporteros
el documental comenzamos la historia de
hoy es en antioquia en colombia la
periodista isabel a bernal realizó un
documental al que llamó verde como el
oro y retrata los temores de los
campesinos locales por el impacto
ambiental y social que traería un
proyecto minero llamado quebradona con
el que la multinacional anglogold
ashanti pretende explotar por más de 20
años 49 millones de toneladas de cobre
oro y otros minerales uno de los más
grandes planes extractivos que ha visto
colombia en los últimos años el
documental que veremos en segundos fue
financiado por la beca rain forest fund
del pulitzer centre y busca construir
una conversación ciudadana que le pide a
la autoridad nacional de licencias
ambientales en la de colombia que niegue
la licencia para que las comunidades que
habitan en esas montañas junto a
especies como el oso andino también
conocido como oso de anteojos sigan
teniendo autonomía sobre su territorio
isabel bernal ella es la directora de
este documental isabella gracias por
estar con nosotros y cuál fue o cuáles
fueron las dificultades que se encontró
en la realización de este documental
bueno uno de los grandes retos que
tuvimos durante el rodaje de verde como
el oro fue en principio localizar las
coordenadas de la zona de intervención
de anglogold ashanti porque nosotros si
queríamos ser muy muy precisos con
con lo que estaba y vamos a decir en la
escena de los render por ejemplo esa
zona es esos paisajes que se muestran a
y sobre los cuales luego se proyecta el
render corresponden específicamente a
las zonas que anglo contiene
determinadas para sus una intervención
si entonces ejemplo el cráter no si
queríamos ser muy muy precisos con esas
coordenadas y nos tomó mucho tiempo
durante el rodaje y localizar esas zonas
en el territorio eso por un lado y por
otro creo que también la filmación de
veloso pues porque es un sujeto que es
impredecible y que nos demandaba
muchísima paciencia y nos demandó
quedaron muchas horas esperando sobre
todo vamos evitar una mirada clínica
sobre el animal no queríamos cómo hacer
una mirada
como forense sino más bien muy cercana a
él que nos permitiera casi que sentí la
respiración sentí la textura del pelo
entonces eso nos significó estar mucho
tiempo esperando este momento y
acercarnos muchísimo a él yo creo que
tal vez esas fueron fueron dos de los
grandes retos que tuvimos durante el
rodaje
gracias isabel a invitados entonces
saber verde como el oro
[Música]
si eso no lo he visto
toda la vida ha estado para deshacer el
e el que manda ahí
además de él huele mucho entonces así
bueno está aquí no se deja ver
y si uno se le arrima mucho también le
puede poner una muñeca defensiva
y también lo abre como una palma
eso animales también con un a veces
y me lo encontré comiendo carne
desde lejos lo vi así
y me han dicho lleve estas carpetas y
trabajar comer de los
y le tiende a silas copeta
y me quedé un rato así mirándolo me
pregunto cuándo
te hablo en el estado midiendo ya sería
el ruido y esos alivia y si corres
azaroso
cuando se casaba por ejemplo con el
perro
era un tiempo difícil de el animal
que no soltaba el perro el perseguía en
cueva el animal y comenzaba uno a
escarbar y escarbarle medio día 45 horas
y pocas veces lo sacaba uno
a cuerdas ayudadas tan horrible uno con
un recato no con una palanca haciendo
web además que cuando terminó a las tres
o cuatro la tarde para y sin almorzar
tenía que irse para la casa sin fin el
animal
entonces y quedaba uno con ganas de irse
a buscar otro que porque está muy
difícil y el pasaba lo mismo siempre así
casi siempre no había seis o siete veces
y de siete veces que saliera si acaso
una vez cogió el animal
si era de la época pues esa época de la
cacería con perro fue como más bien
diversión porque pocas veces corría uno
enseñar
cuando más se mató animal era por
ejemplo cuando había nada una cosecha de
frijol o de racacha o de yuca que hay
una pena que ella hiciera obligatorio ir
pues a cuidar el trabajador o
porque cuando la persona a veces cuando
la me están dando la yuca le colocan un
cebadero
que esa fue la colocan por ejemplo a un
racismo en aquella parte cogía en él
el fierro
por ejemplo esta posición ha gastado el
racimo
y uno aquí
horas y horas cansado mate zancudo de l
de pronto a veces al día y uno no le
daba no le daba el tiro porque estaba
uno moviéndose entre los sentidos ellos
y cuando de pronto estaba de malas el
animalito que uno logra ver que llegaba
en todas y si llegaba o mitch
ya para lujo eso lo recuerdo con esto en
casa ahora
y eso ya pasó la historia
son las 10 de la mañana y mirad qué
maravilla de neblina está ahora
la sabiduría de la naturaleza como va
subiendo en la lluvia de noche se va
cargando a mitad montaña
se va enredando ahí en los árboles y
empieza a gotear y empieza a alimentar
todas quebradas cierto
si es que mira que por ejemplo dentro de
las cosas que la mina no tuvo no tiene
en cuenta cuando habla de los de los
animales que hay es primero no tuvo en
cuenta al oso y segundo lo único que
hizo fue hacer un listado de las
especies que hay es decir el problema no
hay de un listado el problema es bueno
como se relacionan cuántos hay de cada
uno de esos de esas especies y logró
colocaron en la en la lista del oso no
no no aparece que porque no lo vieron
seguramente cierto no conocen el
territorio nunca entrevistaron a nadie
nunca pusieron una cámara trampa cierto
entonces pues como complicado hablar de
lo que no quieren hablar cierto y es un
territorio pues que los ha usado desde
tiempos inmemoriales y teniendo pues
claro que los osos son unos sembradores
de bosque ciertos son los jardineritos
también cultivos también cultivan cierta
en la medida que comen pepas tumban los
cardones se los comen si tumban ramas y
en esa medida van brotando con la luz
del sol que logra llegar
al piso logran germinar las las
semillitas que habían ahí no porque son
pequeños son pequeñas poblaciones por el
tema de que como ha sido tan afectado el
bosque cierto entonces eso ha
contribuido eso y la casa de la cacería
lo que llamamos la pérdida del espacio
de la pérdida de hábitat y la cacería
contribuyeron o han contribuido a que
las poblaciones bajen mucho bajen mucho
en otras partes lo hay si digamos que si
uno va a bolívar encuentra registros de
osos y uno antes en la misma cordillera
hacia en la misma cordillera ahí hay
buenos individuos digamos que no es los
que uno esperaría he oído decir que es
muy escaso pues en el mundo es escaso y
parece que aquí es una de las partes
donde el más escaso es que empezando por
qué es que es el único oso que hay en
suramérica y el único oso que hay en
colombia sino en toda suramérica sino en
cinco países no más
entonces si es tan escaso y es tan
valioso dónde está pues la sabiduría
para proteger el área de él claro porque
nosotros campeón os dije no tumbe el
bosque no haga esto ya ser bonito no lo
vaya a tumbar y llega una multinacional
y le dan licencia para que tumbe no uno
sino todo exactamente es donde uno ve
bueno cuál es la lógica con la que
estamos trabajando o conservamos o
acabamos con todo
por qué
ellos es que dicen que también no está
amenazado con eso que porque ellos están
en otro lado y que no hay que la misma
cordillera explotando con el helicóptero
pero cuánto tiempo pero estaba hace
cuatro meses ahí andan de garras toda
esta parte del 'no todo esto todo esto
lo exploraron esa gente para que no van
a decir que no que no se van a meter si
se metieron allá ya llevan viniendo pero
yo dije que no que yo están en el
lindero jericó y tam espero que la
exploración que están haciendo es allá y
que esto no es perdí caos que además del
oso no va hasta por allá
y estaba viendo ahorita que meten unos
taladros que tienen 800 y más metros por
entre la tierra y van sacando entonces
eso lo meten por allá y sale por aquí ya
que perjudicaba estamos de todas maneras
no es que esa maquinaria trabajando
según parece en la física en la marcha
eso ya hay seguridad privada ya no
pueden tener nadie ya creo que hay mucha
maquinaria y se ha trabajando es por
dentro cuando menos piensas porque eso
va muy lejos y usted cree que porque no
puede entrar nadie porque no miren eso
no venga de una montaña de esas y ahí ya
ellos están por años lejos con el oro
monto navidad
y ellos de todas maneras vienen diciendo
que van a hacer una minería responsable
y que equilibrada y que no sé qué pero
uno dice y qué responsable y qué
equilibrada va a ser una cosa que se va
a sacar un metal que está profundo y
encima hay una montaña para volverla a
colocar ahí yo como la van a volver a
colocar bien que vuelven y dejan que
casi como estaban secas hay que pintar
pajaritos de oro para poder proponer
pero pues yo digo que la oportunidad de
nosotros en el momento es decir no hoy
pues porque todos vivimos aquí de
agricultura sembramos una racacha
sembramos una yuca sembramos frijol ya
lo tenemos todos miren que cuando empezó
la pandemia esa peste que a todo el
mundo no apretó aquí era la única parte
donde estaba la panela lo llamamos por
sal y la carne de pronto y lo otro
estaba cuando otros trabajar entonces
una ventaja traver era de todas maneras
mientras con una cosa de esas ya uno
puede que pronto de cariño forma legal y
después que decir que miren qué
donde a usted sus nietos y sus hijos ya
que el sector ha afectado menos la
pandemia al sector agrícola porque ahí
hemos estado sostenido nunca hemos
tenido esos encierros tan claros que
tiene la gente en la ciudad si nosotros
tenemos que vender las tierras por
problemas de la minería porque a uno
cuando esa gente llega o por las buenas
o las malas lo sacan a uno porque porque
ahora le ofrecen por la finca y si no
quiere vender
a la buena o la mala lo saca
ya hay que desocupar porque es que hay
debajo hay un actual que lan y tam o
nosotros si dicen que uno no tiene
derechos y nuevo como a dos metros y el
resto que el subsuelo del gobierno eso
es lo que pasa entonces el gobierno le
da el aval a esa gente para extraer esa
esa minería en todo nosotros mismos
dientes arruinados del gobierno a toda
hora porque diario deben encima de
nosotros porque también se necesita la
minería creo yo porque hay mucha
maquinaria digamos ahora hay mucha
tecnología
pero prácticamente detrás de esos
aparatos las que van a llamar con el
campesino también para que tanta
tecnología si no hay quien trabajar esa
es la otra que nosotros por ejemplo
cuando compramos un celular y que
compramos hay un poquito de eso que
están sacando ahí cuando de compra en la
cámara ahí se compra un poquito desde
entonces va a tocar dejar de ir usando
las cosas así porque esa minería
nosotros explota el oro sino que hay
otros metales que esa gente como que se
llevan también pues no tiene muy poco
conocimiento de eso pero uno oye si vive
que que si saqueo como mucha cosa y
todas esas montañas el computador para
el muchacho para que estudia y lleva de
esas cosas que sacaron de ahí
el nacer todo esto río acá no ha
producido ningún problema ni a usted lo
han amenazado por eso ni nada de esas
cosas pero al entrar la minería si hay
amenazas y hay problemas por ejemplo a
mí yo tuve una amenaza por decir unas
tropas en contra de la sociedad del río
justamente dio cuenta del mismo
teléfono que me dieran que hablaban y
que no sé cuántas que yo están ayudando
a ningún río y que si no ya no
el ladrón está tan señor y al señor como
un pirata hay una canción que dice eso
estamos montados aquí y usted le
pregunta por ejemplo por qué esto de
tanta muerte de los líderes sociales
porque eso porque no le conviene a
ciertos sectores
eso sí es muy delicado tema pero si
nosotros
porque ellos tienen la autoridad de
todas maneras de muchas gracias por
muchas gracias a esas guisanderas están
trabajando muy duro
d
ah
cómo
[Música]
se utiliza un método que se llama
perforación y volador volver a avanzar
volver a perforar volver a poner el
explosivo vuelve a la perforación agua
la voladora material ese es él si yo voy
avanzando no hay que desterrar no nos
vamos a estar en total 38 años en el
territorio como de sus recursos y
minerales en progresos sociales hasta
relatarán y regresar es a partir del
aprovechamiento esos recursos minerales
se convierte en desarrollo bueno
nosotros no encontramos evidencia en el
área de intervención del proyecto ni en
el área de influencia en la presencia
los nosotros no están afectando la
conectividad de las especies o
expresiones proyectivas la minería con
propósito
imaginemos cómo va a ser la zona dónde
va a quedar la transformación de los
materiales de la mina cerca del cauca
más bajitos que aquí más caliente
yo no soy ningún gran conocedor
yo soy tengo unos mínimos conocimientos
ni son la o la obligatoriedad de estar
en el territorio lo que me lo ha
permitido y que tengo un poquito de
tiempo pero la mina la primer mina de 5
estos van a ser cinco
no se me asuste van a ser cinco la
primer mina que es quebrado na queda
quebrado no quebrado es quebrado nada en
jericó en jericó entonces queda en los
límites entre también y jericó nos
venden el cuento que va a ser en jericó
pero queda
al ladito de allá
de la línea divisoria
al ladito de aquí a la historia aquí de
esta línea divisoria que en este mapa
queda aquí a 300 metros de la línea
divisoria qué quiere decir eso
pues que queda entre clark y koi támesis
pues qué quiere decir eso porque le dice
que no se afecta también si están ahí
pues el lindero es como si éste
alambrado que separa las dos fincas una
serpiente le impidiera pasar al otro
lado porque hay un alambrado usted que
piensa
pasará o no pasará a una serpiente por
ahí eso es porque será porque no sabe
leer o será porque puede pasar porque
será que no estamos incluidos en el
estudio impacto ambiental pues te
imaginas pero al no ser minería ya así
vamos a estar afectaban a hacer minería
en la parte alta en el segundo piso de
nuestro municipio y entrar primer piso
es que no nos va a pasar nada pero es
que es muy grave el tema porque es que
nosotros tenemos aquí en el sur aquí en
el sur
así como lo muestra el mapa aquí en el
sur en la cuenca del conde y el cártama
tenemos la comunidad indígena néstor y
es increíble que si hay minería
en nuestro territorio como de hecho lo
está viendo los indígenas tienen que ser
términos en cuenta porque solo una
población con derechos especiales néstor
la constitución del 91 nos muestra que
son derechos especiales entonces sabe
que tendremos que hacer
eso sí ando así pues entonces no
tuvieron en cuenta los indígenas ni a
las comunidades tampoco violan la
constitución porque habría que hacer una
consulta previa o sea llamar a consulta
previa a los indígenas usted cree que yo
van a estar de acuerdo con que nos
perforó en el territorio cuando su
concepto de la madre tierra es
terriblemente profundo terriblemente
arraigado en su corazón y es que debiera
ser el concepto de todos es decir nos
perjudicamos esto los indígenas y las
comunidades en general claro
agua soja símbolo de cambio la banda
'mein kampf' mammana maule puente
viajado entre el cielo y the urban a un
puente cuba aun jamás conocí a baraja
osos o su cuento las fuentes vidas a un
cielo grazzini los bares
me invita sabuesos a ratos a una
historia no dependamos al apartado jabón
horas sin primer hombre en a un mundo de
buschi nada humano lleva impasibles el
primer día su primer y mosquera un autor
historia de mis papás chipitas actos
actualmente entera símbolo ni para patxi
terna
la cubos y hueso la minería a nosotros
los indígenas los minerales son los
huesos de la naturaleza son los huesos
de la madre tierra es como sea meter un
algo y sacar la costilla a uno y uno ya
no va a quedar lo mismo
es como romper los huesos de los pies y
a uno no va a caminar lo mismo
entonces y nosotros como indígena
miramos eso las iniciales magos en oren
más abajo pedro al al enfermar la madre
tierra ese cuerpo tan es tan elegante de
la naturaleza también se enferman los
hijos de las madres tierras que son
nosotros los seres humanos hablamos en
ver a campesinos comunidades afros
mestizos etcétera
y aparte de eso la sangre se contamina
de la madre tierra y que es la sangre
más dura el agua es el agua de la madre
tierra las años se contaminan
cuando me casé la mujer no comía esther
la raca cheque porque eso sabía muy mal
y ahora no hay arracacha no trabajo
a ella le gusta mucho pero no comía
a los todos como que
me pone a ver y la otra vez como que
casi nadie comunidades ahora casi todo
mundo le gusta los que es muy buena
una sopa de esto yo creo que más que
todo es por lo que está escasa
como tortillita y web y consulta
pero si cuando había y en esa época yo
sí que cultivaban a uno viejo y
y con tanto que hacer no le das pero
como primero yo no tenía mucho
entonces llevaba muchas casas que se
quedan o no a mí no me gusta eso y
amontonando usted aquí sí un poquito por
este light pero era mejor ir sacando
playas contigo como para la vida
para ir recorriendo esta pastilla
anoche estuve soñando que hablaba con
mis abuelos y le pregunté llorando qué
puedo hacer por mi pueblo aquí ya no
existe paz aquí ya no hay libertad
aquí ya no pasa un día sin algo que la
menta
aquí el hermano tradiciones y se ufanan
al tradicional y el hermano el humilde y
luego vuelve a cobrar aquí todo está al
revés y nadie quiere trabajar ya las
gentes que trabajan las arrastran sin
piedad
aladro tratan señor y al señor como un
pirata ver que hay que aplastar la flor
y reventarle la manta se volvió palabras
dioses y hay sin hechos mil corbatas el
amor es un amor en la medida que paga
de la iglesia suya abuelo ya casi no
queda nada
los curas que no son la quieren
manipulada
y bueno
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros el documental recuerde que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web más
24 punto com para ver extensión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima
[Música]